This is the 99% Invisible City. I'm Roman Mars. Five years ago, we came out with a book, and thanks to all you beautiful nerds, it immediately landed on the New York Times bestseller list. It was filled with dozens of design stories from cities around the world. Some were brand new stories, some were based on episodes of the show, and others grew out of 99PI articles by the book's co-author, Kurt Kolstad. And the idea was to create a kind of field.
这里是99%隐形城市。我是罗曼·马尔斯。五年前，我们出版了一本书，多亏了你们这群可爱的书呆子，它一经推出就登上了《纽约时报》畅销书排行榜。书里装满了来自世界各地城市的数十个设计故事。有些是全新的故事，有些基于节目中的单集，还有一些则是由本书的共同作者库尔特·科尔斯坦德的99PI文章发展而来的。我们的想法是创造一种实地指南。
guide to the city, not any particular city, but a guide to the underlying design principles of every city. The book was called The 99% Invisible City, a field guide to the hidden world of everyday design. And I remember that subtitle took us like a whole lot of time to come up with. Oh, yeah. Many phone calls were made. Much, much was made of that. It was like, hidden versus secret, everyday versus ordinary.
城市指南，不是某个特定的城市，而是所有城市的底层设计原则指南。这本书名为《99%隐形城市：日常设计的隐藏世界实地指南》。我记得我们花了大量时间才想出这个副标题。哦，是的。打了无数电话。为此付出了大量心血。就像是，隐藏与秘密，日常与普通的区别。
Exactly. Oh, yeah, that's right. That's right. And to launch the book, Kurt and I produced a special 99PI episode made of short guidebook style entries recorded in beautiful downtown, Oakland, California. And now to celebrate the fifth anniversary of the book, we're going to share those stories again today. And with that, I'm going to hand the mic back to the Roman Mars of five years ago from October of 2020. For the first time, in a long time, I'm in our office in beautiful downtown, Oakland, California. A couple of people actually still work here.
没错。哦，对了，就是这样。没错。为了新书发布，我和库尔特制作了一集特殊的99PI节目，其中包含简短的指南风格条目，录制于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。现在，为了庆祝该书出版五周年，我们今天将再次分享这些故事。接下来，我把话筒交回给五年前、来自2020年10月的罗曼·马尔斯。很长一段时间以来，我第一次来到我们位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心的办公室。其实还有几个人在这里工作。
Two people can occupy the space without violating any social distancing guidelines. There's two entrances. There's two different bathrooms. There's two different kitchens. I usually work at home. But today, I'm here because our first book, The 99% Invisible City, has just been released into the world. Since it's a guide to the city with stories and histories of the seemingly. mundane things around you, my co-author Kurt Kolstad and I are going to use it to explore all the
两个人占用这个空间也没有违反任何社交距离指南。这里有两个入口。有两个不同的洗手间。有两个不同的厨房。我通常在家工作。但今天我来到这里，是因为我们的第一本书《99%隐形城市》刚刚问世。既然这是一本关于城市及其周围看似平凡事物的故事和历史的指南，我和共同作者库尔特·科尔斯坦德将用它来探索所有的
everyday objects right outside our own headquarters. But before we even leave the office, just looking at the window, there's a brick building next door. And the tops of its walls are dotted with a bunch of square metal plates. These anchor plates are a few inches across. They're pretty thin, and they're spun in a bunch of different orientations. So, even though they're painted to blend in with a brick, once you notice them, they kind of stand out. And you could think of them like giant washers with bolts or rods tying them into the bricks and helping brace them against the facade.
我们总部外面的日常物品。但甚至在我们离开办公室之前，只要看看窗外，隔壁就是一栋砖砌建筑。它的墙顶上点缀着一束方形金属板。这些锚固板有几英寸宽。它们很薄，并且以各种不同的方向旋转。所以，尽管它们被刷成与砖块融为一体的颜色，但一旦你注意到它们，它们就会显得很突出。你可以把它们想象成带螺栓或杆的巨型垫圈，将它们固定在砖块中并帮助支撑它们抵御外墙。
And these ones happen to be square, but I've seen others in the neighborhood that are round or octagonal. In fact, anchor plates like this are pretty common in the Bay Area, in part for seismic reasons. They help make sure that loose bricks don't fall off buildings and hurt people during earthquakes. These particular ones are way up high
这些正好是方形的，但我见过邻里中其他是圆形或八角形的。事实上，像这样的锚固板在湾区相当常见，部分原因是出于抗震考虑。它们有助于确保在地震期间松动的砖块不会从建筑物上掉下来伤到人。这些特定的锚固板位于非常高的地方
where the walls overrun the roof. So there's a parapet up there where the bricks can't be braced against the main building. And so someone installed these and connected them to metal braces on the rooftop that you can't actually see from below. In other places, though, you can see anchor plates all the way down a facade, and in those cases, they have a ton of work to do. They help hold up entire masonry walls that might otherwise be at risk of total collapse.
墙壁延伸出屋顶的地方。所以那里有一个女儿墙，砖块无法靠在主建筑上支撑。因此，有人安装了这些锚固板，并将它们连接到屋顶上从下面实际上看不到的金属支架上。不过，在其他地方，你可以在整个外墙上看到锚固板，在这种情况下，它们有很多工作要做。它们有助于支撑整个砖石墙，否则这些墙可能会有彻底坍塌的风险。
In the book, we have an illustration with a bunch of different shapes that you can look out for in whatever city you're in. There are squares and circles and stars and other geometric forms, but there are also some really ornate ones, like this huge curving S shape that holds up an old, stone wall in Europe. But whether they look good or not so good, they've got a job to do, and they all look better than the alternative, which would be, of course, a pile of stones or bricks. So if you walk outside of our building and look back, you will see a beautiful black ornate fire escape. I love that we have a fire escape on our building. I know a couple of people on the staff, they climb out on it and they watch the city at night. I never do that because I'm a big chicken.
在书中，我们有一张插图，展示了你在身处的任何城市中都可以寻找的各种形状。有正方形、圆形、星星和其他几何形状，但也有一些非常华丽的形状，比如支撑欧洲古老石墙的巨大S形曲线。但无论它们看起来好不好看，它们都有工作要做，而且它们看起来都比替代方案要好，当然，替代方案就是一堆石头或砖块。因此，如果你走出我们的建筑并回过头看，你会看到一个美丽、华丽的黑色防火梯。我很高兴我们的建筑上有一个防火梯。我知道工作人员中的几个人会爬上去，在夜里观赏城市。我从不这样做，因为我是个胆小鬼。
Fire has long been one of the greatest existential threats to a building and its occupants. But fire escapes became widespread kind of late in the game. Back in the 1700s, fire escapes weren't built-in features, but rather mobile ladders on carts hauled to blazes by firemen. Other solutions for escaping a fire in a multi-story building in the 1800s included parachute hats. I think you can imagine both how those looked and how they did not work at all. There was even this widely circulated plan that proposed that if there was a fire that archers from the ground would shoot arrows with ropes attached to them for residents on the upper floors to shimmy down. But eventually, we settled on iron fire escapes attached permanently to a building's facade. Fire escapes are thankfully not used very often, but unfortunately this also means that they can fall into disrepair, especially if a landlord is prone to cutting corners.
长期以来，火灾一直是建筑物及其 occupants 面临的最大生存威胁之一。但防火梯在游戏后期才普及。早在18世纪，防火梯还不是内置设施，而是消防员拖到火灾现场的手推车上的移动梯子。19世纪多层建筑中逃生火灾的其他解决方案包括降落伞帽。我想你可以想象它们的样貌以及它们是如何完全不起作用的。甚至还有一个广泛流传的计划，提议如果发生火灾，地面的弓箭手会射出带有绳索的箭，让高楼层的居民顺着绳索滑下来。但最终，我们确定了永久固定在建筑外墙上的铁制防火梯。谢天谢地，防火梯不常使用，但不幸的是，这也意味着它们可能会失修，特别是如果房东喜欢偷工减料的话。
The infamous triangle shirtways factory fire that killed 146 people in 1911 was a national tragedy that spurred a lot of change in terms of workers' rights. But it also made people look closely at how we need safe and planning. means of egress from buildings in case of emergency. In this instance, one of the things that caused a lot of the deaths was that the fire escape collapsed under the weight of all the people trying to flee for their lives. Since then, and especially today, managing the flow of people during an emergency is a top consideration.
1911年造成146人死亡的臭名昭著的三角衬衫waist工厂大火是一场全国性的悲剧，它推动了工人权利方面的许多变革。但它也让人们密切关注我们需要如何在发生紧急情况时制定安全且有计划的建筑疏散通道。在这种情况下，导致大量死亡的原因之一是防火梯在所有拼命逃生的人的重量下坍塌了。从那时起，尤其是今天，在紧急情况下管理人流是一个首要考虑因素。
It's still not perfect, obviously. If you look around the city, most buildings don't seem to have fire escapes anymore, the newer buildings never do. But looks can be deceiving. These buildings, they do have fire escapes, but they've essentially been swallowed up by buildings evolving into fortified stairs. Fire stairs often double as ordinary staircases used on a daily basis, but they have extra protections and features to make them safer routes of escape during emergencies. So you could be walking on the great granddaughter of this fire escape every day and not even notice it. So right next store to our office, there's a storefront, and the businesses inside and of there have changed over the years.
显然，这仍然不完美。如果你环顾这座城市，大多数建筑似乎不再有防火梯了，较新的建筑从不具备。但外表可能是具有欺骗性的。这些建筑确实有防火梯，但它们基本上已经被演变成加固楼梯的建筑所吞没。消防楼梯通常兼作日常使用的普通楼梯，但它们具有额外的保护和功能，使其成为紧急情况下更安全的逃生路线。所以你可能每天都在走这个防火梯的曾孙女，甚至都没有注意到它。所以就在我们办公室隔壁，有一个店面，里面的企业这些年来一直在变。
But out front, there's this persistent element, and it's a planter. And the planter is kind of recessed into the facade a bit, so the edge of it, the front edge of it, is up against the sidewalk. And the plants and dirt are held in place by this low retaining wall that's maybe a couple inches deep. And, you know, under the best of circumstances, it wouldn't be a great. great place to sit, although I've seen people try. But what makes it really, really unappealing is this row of knobs that they have arrayed along the top of the wall. And we've talked about things like spikes on the show before that swayed people from sitting. But these knobs, they look almost decorative. Like, they're painted black to blend in with the black wall.
但在正前方，有一个持久的元素，那就是一个花坛。花坛稍微向外墙内凹，所以它的边缘，即前边缘，紧靠着人行道。植物和泥土由这堵低矮的挡土墙固定在适当的位置，这堵墙可能只有几英寸深。而且，你知道，在最好的情况下，它也不是一个坐着的好地方，尽管我见过有人尝试。但让它变得非常非常没有吸引力的是沿墙顶排列的一排圆头。我们在节目中讨论过像钉子一样劝阻人们坐下的东西。但这些圆头看起来几乎是装饰性的。比如，它们被漆成黑色，与黑墙融为一体。
They're defensive design, but like in disguise. And when we think about things like, like defensive design or hostile architecture, we tend to imagine obvious things like spikes. But there are a lot of less obvious ones, too. Some places have sprinkler systems that are situated to keep people away rather than to, you know, actually water plants. And in Seattle, there's this one bike rack in particular that's kind of infamous because people started to question, you know, why did somebody put a bike rack there? That's not a place people would normally park their bike.
它们是防御性设计，但却进行了伪装。当我们想到诸如防御性设计或敌对建筑之类的事情时，我们往往会想象到像钉子这样显而易见的东西。但也有许多不太明显的东西。有些地方的喷水灭火系统旨在让人远离，而不是真正给植物浇水。在西雅图，有一个特定的自行车架相当臭名昭著，因为人们开始质疑，为什么有人会在那里放一个自行车架？那不是人们通常停放自行车的地方。
and it turned out that this was put there by the city to keep people from setting up tents and camping on that particular stretch of sidewalk. And, you know, big picture, a lot of these interventions, they don't tackle bigger underlying issues. They just kind of shuffle people around. And to me, that's a good argument for transparency, among other things. Because when you disguise something, you stop conversations from starting around it, right? So once it's clear why something is the way it is, people can start to debate whether or not a given design, quote unquote, solution is humane or equitable or even effective. Looking down on our street corner, you'll see a bunch of spray painted marks.
事实证明，这是市政府放置的，目的是防止人们在该特定路段搭建帐篷露营。而且，从宏观来看，许多这些干预措施并没有解决更大的根本问题。它们只是把人推来推去。对我来说，这是支持透明度的一个很好的论据，除此之外。因为当你伪装某事时，你就阻止了围绕它展开的对话，对吧？因此，一旦清楚了某事为什么是现在这样，人们就可以开始辩论某个所谓的“设计”解决方案是否人道、公平甚至有效。低头看看我们的街角，你会看到一堆喷漆标记。
on the road and on the sidewalk. So here's a fun fact. The first two-page illustration in the book located just before chapter one is an illustration of this very spot. Kurt took the picture from our window. The colorful spray-painted markings are a guide to all the pipes and wires
在路上和人行道上。这里有一个趣事。书中的前两页插图位于第一章之前，正是这个地方的插图。库尔特是从我们的窗户拍下这张照片的。五颜六色的喷漆标记是穿梭于表面之下的所有管道和电线的指南
and tubes criss-crossing below this surface and they are there for a very important reason. In June of 1976, workers were excavating a stretch of Venice Boulevard in Los Angeles, California. and accidentally cut into a hidden petroleum pipeline. The pipe ruptured and pressurized gas ignited into a fireball that engulfed passing cars and adjacent businesses.
交叉纵横，它们的存在有着非常重要的原因。1976年6月，工人们在加利福尼亚州洛杉矶的威尼斯大道（Venice Boulevard）路段进行挖掘时，不小心切入了一条隐藏的石油管道。管道破裂，加压气体被引燃成火球，吞没了过往车辆和相邻企业。
More than two dozen people were injured or killed. This wasn't the first or last tragedy of its kind, but the enormity of this particular disaster helped catalyze the codification of these color-coded utility markings. So in general, anyone excavating on public property is required to contact a regional alert organization before digging into the ground so that the different utility agencies can come out and mark the hazards that may be below. The American National Standards Institute has formalized which colors indicate which utility. So this is my favorite part. So red is for electrical power lines. Orange is for telecommunications. Yellow is for gaseous or combustive materials like natural gas
二十多人受伤或丧生。这并不是同类悲剧中绝无仅有的一次，但这场特殊灾难的严重性有助于推动这些颜色编码的公用设施标记的法典化。因此，总的来说，任何在公共财产上进行挖掘的人都必须在挖掘土地之前联系区域警报组织，以便不同的公用设施机构能够出来标记可能在下方的危险。美国国家标准学会已经正式规定了哪些颜色代表哪种公用设施。所以这是我最喜欢的部分。红色代表电力线。橙色代表电信。黄色代表气态或可燃材料，如天然气
or petroleum. Green is for sewage lines. There are a few other colors, but those are some of the biggies. For some reason, an infinity symbol is used to indicate the beginning or end of a proposed project area, even though an infinity symbol is normally applied to things without a beginning or an end. So, obviously, some colors and symbols are more intuitive than others. But what I love about all this official graffiti is that for this stretch of concrete, we all have x-ray vision if we know how to decode it. So on our block, there's a relatively recent renovations. that added a bunch of traffic calming devices,
或石油。绿色代表污水管道。还有一些其他颜色，但这些是主要的。出于某种原因，无限符号用于指示提议的项目区域的起点或终点，尽管无限符号通常应用于没有起点或终点的事物。因此，很明显，某些颜色和符号比其他颜色和符号更直观。但我喜欢所有这些官方涂鸦的原因是，对于这段混凝土，如果我们知道如何解码，我们所有人都有 X 光视力。所以我们的街区最近进行了一次相对较新的翻新，增加了一系列交通平静化装置，
things like planters and ballards to him in the cars a bit and slow people down and to make it easier to cross the street. And it's pretty good. But further up the street, if you go up a bit, there's a much more traditional and classical and recognizable traffic calming feature, a speed bump. And it's pretty typical. It looks like any other speed bump.
比如花坛和路障，用来稍微限制汽车并放慢人们的速度，使过马路更容易。这很不错。但在街道更上方，如果你再往上走一点，有一个更传统、经典且易于识别的交通平静化设施——减速带。它非常典型。它看起来就像任何其他减速带一样。
It's just a raised stretch of pavement that goes across the lane, and it's meant to slow people down. And in the book, we write about, you know, a bunch of different traffic calming strategies. But there's this one in particular that I really am into. And what it's called sort of depends on who you ask. But if you Google speed cushion, you'll get the right result. And what makes it special is actually pretty simple.
它只是一段穿过车道的凸起路面，旨在让人们慢下来。在书中，我们写了关于许多不同的交通平静化策略的内容。但有一个我特别感兴趣。它叫什么名字取决于你问谁。如果你谷歌搜索“减速垫”（speed cushion），你会得到正确的结果。它特别的地方其实很简单。
It's got these wheel-wide slices cut through it. So if you see one, it actually looks more like three smaller speed bumps side by side. But why? Well, there's space to accommodate emergency vehicles, like ambulances. So for a normal driver of a normal car with normal wheel spacing, it still works like a speed bump. But for a driver rushing to save lives, they can breeze right through without slowing down. And honestly, it's pretty simple. but I think it's quite ingenious.
它上面切开了与车轮同宽的切片。所以如果你看到一个，它实际上看起来更像是三个并排较小的减速带。但为什么呢？嗯，有空间容纳紧急车辆，比如救护车。因此，对于普通车轮间距的普通汽车的普通司机来说，它仍然像减速带一样工作。但对于急于挽救生命的司机来说，他们可以顺利通过而无需减速。老实说，这很简单，但我认为它非常巧妙。
Okay, traffic lights. We already told you about the one in Syracuse, New York, with the green on top of the red as a symbol of Irish pride. But that isn't the only funky thing going on with traffic-like colors in the world. In Japan, their green light is more of a bluish green, And this comes from the fact that their interpretation of the color blue, or ow, that's a-o-ow, as they say. I mean, that's the best I can say, as they say. The color, ow, historically encompasses hues that most English speakers in the West would call green.
好吧，交通灯。我们已经向你们讲述了纽约州雪城的那盏绿灯在红灯之上的交通灯，作为爱尔兰自豪的象征。但这并不是世界上交通灯颜色唯一古怪的事情。在日本，他们的绿灯更偏向蓝绿色，这是因为他们对蓝色的解释，或者说 ow，那是 a-o-ow，正如他们所说的那样。我的意思是，这是我能说得最好的了，正如他们所说的那样。在历史上，ow 这个词涵盖了西方绝大多数英语使用者会称之为绿色的色调。
Japan was not a signatory to the Vienna conventions on road signs and signals, which was this multilateral treaty systematizing road signs, markings, and lights across dozens of countries. And so for nearly 100 years, Japanese stoplights have been labeled blue on official documents, even though many languages would call the color they see on Japanese traffic lights green. So in order to cut down on international confusion, they came to a compromise. In 1973, the government mandated that traffic lights use the bluest shade of green possible. So there's a color that is technically green, but blue enough to be called Al. So if you go to Japan, there are green traffic lights may be more, you know, grew or blaine, but still just keep moving along.
日本并不是《道路交通标志和信号维也纳公约》的缔约国，该公约是一项将几十个国家的道路标志、标线和灯光系统化的多边条约。因此，近100年来，日本的红绿灯在官方文件中被标为蓝色，尽管许多语言会把他们在日本交通信号灯上看到的颜色称为绿色。因此，为了减少国际混乱，他们达成了妥协。1973年，政府强制规定交通信号灯使用尽可能偏蓝的绿色。所以有一种颜色，它在技术上是绿色，但又足够蓝，可以被称为AI。因此，如果你去日本，那里的绿灯可能更多是，你知道的，发绿或发蓝，但别管它，继续往前走就行了。
All as well. While we're in the headspace of Japan by way of Oakland, I want to tell you about the manhole covers of Osaka. Oh my God, they're beautiful. The Oakland manhole covers in our neighborhood are so boring in comparison to those in Osaka. There's one that looks like an ornate woodblock print showing Osaka Castle wrapped in blue waves and white cherry blossoms. And fancy covers dot streets all over the country with pictures of flowers and animals and buildings and bridges and boats and mythical heroes and rising phoenixes. These artistic covers gained popularity in the 1980s when a government bureaucrat named Yasutaki Kameda proposed them as a way to raise awareness of the awesomenessonness. of municipal sewer systems and make no mistake municipal sewer systems are awesome no one should
一切都很好。当我们顺着奥克兰的思路沉浸在日本的氛围中时，我想跟你聊聊大阪的人孔盖。天哪，它们太美了。相比之下，我们社区奥克兰的人孔盖就显得太无聊了。有一个看起来像是一幅华丽的木刻版画，展现了被蓝色海浪和白色樱花包裹的大阪城。精美的人孔盖点缀在全国各地的街道上，上面印有花朵、动物、建筑、桥梁、小船、神话英雄和浴火重生的凤凰。这些富有艺术感的人孔盖在20世纪80年代开始流行，当时一位名叫安孝龟田的政府官员提出，可以用它们来提高人们对市政排污系统巨大价值的认识。别搞错，市政排污系统太棒了，谁都不应该
need to be convinced of that but he wanted to levy more taxes to improve and expand the sewer network and so the fancy covers were the focus of a visibility and appreciation campaign he even encouraged different cities to compete over who had the best lids now you could easily spend a good hour marveling at japanese manhole covers online in fact i encourage you to do just that these Thent ones, though they kind of suck. But municipal water systems, they're still amazing. So if there's one thing I always notice when I walk around downtown Oakland, it's this giant array of stuff on top of this tall building a few blocks from our office.
需要被说服去相信这一点，但他想征收更多的税来改善和扩大下水道网络，所以这些精美的人孔盖就成了一场提高知名度和赞赏度运动的焦点。他甚至鼓励不同的城市去竞争谁拥有最好的井盖。现在，你完全可以花上整整一个小时在网上惊叹于日本的人孔盖，事实上，我鼓励你亲自去看看。不过，这些旧的井盖确实有点逊色。但市政供水系统依然令人惊叹。所以，如果说我走在奥克兰市中心时总是注意到一件事，那就是在我们办公室几个街区外的一栋高楼顶上，有着一大堆各种各样的东西。
And it's hard to tell from far away and from down on the ground. But these things are huge, like the size of SUVs. They're curved at the top and they taper as they go down and they face in various. directions. But what are they? Well, they're microwave relay towers and they're vestiges of this really remarkable technology from the mid-1900s. Back in the 1950s, AT&T engaged in this huge nationwide construction project. The company deployed a whole network of these relays across the country. And sure, okay, long networks existed already, but not like this. What I find most amazing about these relays is that they were wireless and required
从远处和地面上很难看清它们。但这些东西非常巨大，差不多有SUV那么大。它们的顶部是弯曲的，越往下越窄，并且朝向不同的方向。但它们是什么呢？好吧，它们是微波中继塔，是20世纪中期这项真正卓越的技术的遗迹。早在20世纪50年代，美国电话电报公司（AT&T）就参与了一项全美范围内的巨大建设工程。该公司在全国各地部署了整个中继网络。当然，好吧，长途网络以前就已经存在了，但绝不是这样的。我对这些中继塔感到最神奇的是，它们是无线的，并且需要
lines of sight, which means every array had to be visible to the others around it in order to relay signals. So these are point-to-point relays, and they bounced information from coast to coast across the entire United States. For decades, they connected cities to cities across these vast expanses, you could see them up on mountain tops, just everywhere across the country. If you Google a map of them, it's really incredible how extensive they were. And now, of course, in the days of fiber optics and satellites, they're basically obsolete, and some of them are long gone.
视线对齐，这意味着每个天线阵列都必须能够被周围的其他阵列看到，以便中继信号。所以这些是点对点中继，它们跨越整个美国，将信息从一个海岸弹射到另一个海岸。几十年来，它们跨越这些广袤的土地将城市与城市连接起来，你可以在山顶上看到它们，在全国各地的任何地方都能看到。如果你在谷歌上搜索它们的地图，它们的覆盖范围如此之广，真的是令人难以置信。当然，在光纤和卫星时代，它们现在基本上已经过时了，其中一些早已消失不见。
But many are still up, like these ones in Oakland. Alas, one of my favorite sets that I really liked in Minneapolis got taken down, recently. It formed this kind of crown around the top of this building downtown. And so you can't go look for that particular one anymore, but you can see an illustration of it in our book. And some relays are still up because it's just too much hassle to dismantle them. And there's really no reason to. But in other cases, like this tower in Los Angeles, they are factored into the architecture itself. So they're like made to fit into the design of the building. And in part, that makes them harder to spot because, you know, you don't really know what they're there for and they could just be kind of an architectural flourish.
但许多仍然屹立不倒，就像奥克兰的这些一样。唉，我在明尼阿波利斯非常喜欢的一组最近被拆除了。它在市中心这栋建筑的顶部形成了一种类似皇冠的形状。所以你不能再去寻找那个特定的塔了，但你可以在我们的书中看到它的插图。有些中继塔仍然保留着，因为拆除它们的麻烦太大了。而且确实也没有理由去拆。但在其他情况下，比如洛杉矶的这座塔，它们被融入了建筑本身。所以它们被设计成契合建筑的设计风格。在某种程度上，这使得它们更难被发现，因为，你知道的，你并不真正知道它们是用来做什么的，它们可能只是一种建筑装饰。
And even in cases where they do stand out more, they're not always easy to see because the tops of buildings are covered with a lot of stuff like HVAC systems and satellite dishes. But once you know what you're looking for, you'll just start seeing them everywhere. Most of the numbered streets downtown are one way, which means they have white-dashed center lines that divide the lanes. This innovation is credited to one man, Edward N. Hines. He was a road booster and a member of the Wayne County Road Commission in Michigan in the early 20th century, when cars were just getting more widespread on roads. The story goes, he was driving on a country road behind a milk truck that was leaking its cargo, and this inspired him. to invent lane dividing center lines. This always struck me as a ridiculous story.
即使在它们更引人注目的情况下，它们也并不总是容易被看到，因为建筑物的顶部覆盖着很多东西，比如暖通空调系统和卫星天线。但是一旦你知道自己在找什么，你就会开始到处看到它们。市中心的大多数编号街道都是单向的，这意味着它们有分割车道的白色虚线中心线。这项创新归功于一个人，爱德华·N·海恩斯。他是20世纪初密歇根州韦恩县道路委员会的一名道路倡导者和成员，当时汽车刚刚在道路上变得越来越普遍。故事是这样的，他正驾驶在一辆漏着货物的送奶卡车后面的乡间小路上，这启发了他
But anyway, however, he got the inspiration, thanks to Heinz, the first stripe of paint dividing lanes was laid down in Wayne County, which includes Detroit, and from there, lines began to be drawn through curves and danger zones to encourage cars to stick to their side in those particularly hazardous spots. And then eventually, they appeared on all roads in the county and then across the state. Today, roadways across the U.S. feature millions of miles of paint from coast to coast. Heinz certainly left an indelible mark on the world, even if that milk truck story is bullshit. So there's a lot of construction going on right now in Oakland.
发明了划分车道的中心线。这总是让我觉得是一个荒谬的故事。但无论如何，不管他是如何受到启发，多亏了海恩斯，韦恩县（包括底特律）铺设了第一条划分车道的油漆标线，从那以后，开始在弯道和危险地带画线，以鼓励汽车在那些特别危险的地方靠自己的车道行驶。然后最终，它们出现在该县的所有道路上，然后遍布整个州。今天，全美各地的公路从一个海岸到另一个海岸都有数百万英里的标线。海恩斯无疑在世界上留下了不可磨灭的印记，即使那个送奶卡车的故事纯属胡扯。所以奥克兰现在有很多建设工程。
A lot of sidewalks are torn up or closed down in downtown area. A lot of beautiful murals, though, around. But if you're walking down the sidewalk, a few blocks from our office, you can see these little plaques embedded underfoot. And this one is pretty clearly worded. It says private property permission to pass over revocable at any time. Some of them a bit more cryptic. They say things like space within building lines not dedicated, which can be kind of hard to parse, but the message is the same. It's basically, hey, you can walk here, but just so you know,
市中心有很多行人路被挖开或封闭。不过周围有很多漂亮的壁画。但是如果你走在人行道上，离我们办公室几个街区远的地方，你可以看到这些镶嵌在脚下的牌匾。这块牌匾上的文字很清楚。上面写着：私人财产，准许通行，可随时撤销。其中一些有点更晦涩。它们写着诸如“建筑线内的空间未奉献”之类的话，这可能有点难以理解，但传达的意思是一样的。基本上就是，嘿，你可以在这里走路，但你要知道，
this is technically private property. And sometimes owners will, you know, build right up to the property line or, you know, put landscaping out that marks off the edge of their territory. But when they don't, this is a way for them to maintain their ownership. And so some install these shiny middle plaques and others just stamp messages like these right into the concrete. And effectively, they're telling you, hey, you're on private property in a place that you might not think is private property. So it might feel like a public sidewalk, but it's not. And if you look down a sidewalk, you can often see a bigger pattern, like a series of these forming a long dashed line. And that, of course, marks out the property's edge.
这在技术上是私人财产。有时业主会，你知道的，直接建造到产权边界，或者，你知道的，设置标记出他们领地边缘的景观。但当他们没有这样做时，这是他们维持所有权的一种方式。因此，一些人安装了这些闪亮的中间牌匾，而另一些人则直接将这样的话语印在混凝土上。实际上，他们在告诉你，嘿，你在一个你可能不认为是私人财产的地方踩在私人财产上。所以它可能感觉像是一个公共人行道，但并不是。如果你顺着人行道往下看，你经常可以看到一个更大的图案，比如一连串这样的图案形成长长的虚线。当然，这标志着财产的边界。
And then at the corner, you might find a right angled version. And that's, of course, to mark out the corner of the property. So together, these form an outline of the building, property footprint, and they're important for building owners because of something called adverse possession. Now, the laws around this vary from place to place, but the basic idea is that if you don't explicitly reserve your property rights somehow, you could lose them. So the easement markers are there in case the owners want to build out later.
然后在拐角处，你可能会发现一个直角版本。当然，那是为了标出房产的拐角。因此，这些组合在一起构成了建筑物的轮廓、房产占地面积，对于建筑业主来说，它们很重要，原因是一种叫做“逆权占有”的东西。现在，有关这方面的法律因地而异q，但基本的想法是，如果你没有以某种方式明确保留你的产权，你可能会失去它们。因此，地役权标记的存在是为了以防业主以后想要扩建。
But in the meantime, they're also conceding some space for semi-public use, which is not And once you recognize what these markers signify and start to see them, they'll also start to see open spaces differently and recognize that there are invisible lines dividing public and private property, or at least invisible until, you know, you start reading the flags. Those are just a handful of stories from the 99% Invisible City, inspired by the things on our street. When you get the book, you can explore about 400 pages of similar stories. And if you listen to me reading the audiobook, it's about 11 hours. You can put it on at
但与此同时，它们也让出了一些空间用于半公共用途，这并非不重要。一旦你认出了这些标记的含义并开始看到它们，你也会以不同的方式看待开放空间，并认识到存在着划分公共和私人财产的无形界限，或者至少在你知道开始阅读这些标志之前是无形的。这些只是来自《99%隐形城市》的一小部分故事，灵感来自于我们街道上的事物。当你拿到这本书时，你可以探索大约400页类似的故事。如果你听我读有声书，大约有11个小时。你可以把它放在
bedtime. You can listen all the way through the night without having to queue up another episode or listen to a furniture ad, although I like the furniture ads. It is an interesting time to be alive and an interesting. time to be putting out this book, since we're not really traveling and generally sticking close to home. This is accidentally a perfect field guide for this moment. It's a guide to the wonder of the built world right in your own neighborhood using examples from all over the globe. Maybe it will be a comfort to you. It was designed to be a good companion and to bring more joy in the world. We're trying to get it out to as many people as possible and expand our little tribe of plaque readers,
睡前听。你可以一整夜地听完，而不必排队等待另一集或者听家具广告，尽管我喜欢家具广告。这是一个活着的有趣时代，也是一个出版这本书的有趣时代，因为我们并没有真正去旅行，大体上都待在家里。这偶然间成了当下完美的实地指南。它是一本指南，带你领略就在你自己的街区里、利用来自全球各地例子的建造世界的奇妙。也许这会给你带来一丝安慰。它旨在成为一个好伴侣，为世界带来更多的快乐。我们正试图把它带给尽可能多的人，并扩大我们的小型牌匾阅读者部落，
design fanatics, and curious urbanists. You can get a copy for yourself and your friends and your family at 99PI.org slash book. Coming up, Kurt and I talk about some of the behind the scenes of making the book and answer many questions people have been asking about the process. Stay with us. So I'm talking with Kurt Kolstad. He's the digital director of 99% Invisible and the co-author of the book. and we want to answer a lot of the questions that we've been asked
设计狂热分子和充满好奇的城市规划者。你可以在 99PI.org/book 为自己、朋友和家人买上一本。接下来，我和柯特将讨论制作这本书的一些幕后花絮，并回答人们在整个过程中一直在问的许多问题。请继续收听。所以我在和柯特·科尔斯塔德交谈。他是《99%隐形》的数字总监兼该书的合著者。我们想回答很多我们一直被问到的问题
as we've been putting together the book over the last couple of years. Yeah, and some of these are questions that have come up, you know, over and over again, and so I've sort of distilled them down and said, okay, like which ones are the ones that people are asking them most? And we came up with these questions that seem to sort of synthesize the things that people are interested in knowing more about. Right. So the first one is about the process of gathering material and picking topics.
在过去几年里我们一直在整理这本书的时候。是的，其中有些问题是，你知道的，一遍又一本地出现，所以我把它们浓缩了一下，然后说，好吧，哪些是大家问得最多的？我们想出了这些问题，它们似乎能够综合人们更想了解的事情。没错。所以第一个关于收集材料和挑选话题的过程。
and organizing all of the book. I mean, one of the things that we had working for us and against us was the 10 years of the show. So there's a lot of like information, information presented in different ways, tons of stuff that's in the book that, you know, never has appeared on a show before. So let's talk a little bit about how we organize the book. There's this joke I've been telling friends, you know, if you're going to write a book, maybe write it about one thing instead of a hundred things. And, you know, it's a really unique challenge to try to bring all of these stories together under one roof and to figure out, you know, not just what to include, but how to, how to structure the whole thing. Going way back, this is the thing that we first started talking about, like my first text file that has the field guide idea sitting in it is from June 2017. we started to think about, okay, how might this work? What kinds of things might we want to include? And I started writing articles and we started doing shows with that in the back of our mind, like which things are we covering or not covering that would make sense to include in a book about cities and design. And then in 2018, we started to really sit down with this thing. And we started working on this giant spreadsheet.
以及整理整本书。我的意思是，对我们有利又对我们不利的事情之一就是节目的10周年。所以有很多类似的信息，以不同方式呈现的信息，书中大量的内容，你知道的，以前从未在节目中出现过。所以我们来谈谈我们是如何组织这本书的。我一直在跟朋友们开玩笑道，如果你要写一本书，也许就写一件事，而不是一百件事。你知道的，试图将所有这些故事汇聚到一个屋檐下，不仅要想好包含什么，还要想好如何构建整个架构，这是一个非常独特的挑战。回溯到很久以前，这是我们最初开始讨论的事情，就像我的第一个包含实地指南想法的文本文档可以追溯到2017年6月。我们开始思考，好吧，这会怎么运作？我们可能想包含哪些类型的东西？我开始写文章，我们开始带着这种想法制作节目，我们在节目中涉及或未涉及哪些内容，如果将其纳入一本关于城市和设计的书中会很有意义。然后在2018年，我们开始真正坐下来着手这件事。我们开始制作这个巨大的电子表格。
Right. Which was a list of every article that you've ever written and every episode that we've ever done. And a bunch of ideas on top of that. And there were all of these different tabs. It was this massive thing. It was really something to behold. Yeah. And then you and I went through and we rated them on a scale to one to five of what type of things would be included in the book that each of us is conceiving in our mind before it had actually been put together. Right. And that was sort of this initial weeding. out process, whereas like, okay, if you say it's a one and I say it's a five, maybe we should talk about it. But of course, there are a lot of places where we just agreed. It's like, well, this has to be in the book. This is a story we need to tell. And one of the ways that I've explained it to other people, too, is like, you know, you had this idea, and maybe I'm oversimplifying
没错。那是一份你写过的每一篇文章和我们做过的每一期节目的清单。除此之外还有一堆想法。而且有所有这些不同的标签。这是一个庞大的东西。真的让人叹为观止。是的。然后你和我一起过了一遍，我们按照1到5的评分标准对这些内容进行了打分，看看在实际拼凑成书之前，我们各自心中构想的书里应该包含哪些类型的内容。没错。这可以说是最初的筛选过程，就好像，好吧，如果你说这是1分，而我说这是5分，也许我们应该讨论一下。但当然，在很多地方我们是不谋而合的。就像，好吧，这必须写进书里。这是一个我们需要讲述的故事。我向其他人解释过的一种方式也是，你知道的，你当时有这个想法，也许我有点过分简化了
a little, but you had this idea of including the best possible stories, which is a great idea. I had this idea of, you know, making sure it all made sense as a book, you know, making sure there were sort of arcs within stories, but also between stories and sections and chapters. And I think that tension was actually a really productive tension. You were sort of checking me on, are you just trying to fit this in because you kind of want it to make more sense as a bigger thing? Right, right. Or is it actually a good story? Yeah. One of the other tensions was this idea of like how much to be a field guide. that related to what was happening in most cities and how much to tell, you know, the best and most interesting story possible. And I think we, I think we walked the line really well, but it was definitely something we thought about each step of the way. Like, I have a particular affinity
一点，但你当时的想法是把最好的故事都收录进去，这真的是个绝妙的主意。而我的想法是，你知道的，确保这一切作为一个整体都说得通，你知道的，确保故事内部以及故事、部分和章节之间存在某种弧线。我认为这种张力实际上是一种非常富有成效的张力。你当时在某种程度上是在审视我，看看我是否只是想把这个硬塞进去，因为你有点想让它作为一个更大的整体更有意义？没错，没错。还是说它本身就是一个好故事？是的。另一个张力是关于实地指南属性的占比，即它应该跟大多数城市正在发生的事情相关，还是应该尽可能多地讲述最好、最有趣的故事。我想我们，我想我们把这条界限把握得非常好，但这绝对是我们一路走来在每个阶段都在思考的问题。比如，我对那种
for kind of the most interesting story about the most everyday or mundane thing. Like, that's my favorite version of this. That's kind of the heart of the field guide as a concept. But there's so many things that don't quite fit into that, that we just were just excited. about, you know, like, especially new things. Like, when you would come back with some research about stuff that, you know, we never covered in the show, those were my favorite, because I often get, you know, like, if I've covered it, I'm like, I'm like, oh, I know it. I know it already. And so, like, when he came back with, like, Battenberg and various other things, like, that was really the type of thing that I was, like, really, really jazzed about when it came to putting the book together.
关于最日常或最平凡事物的最有趣故事有着特殊的喜爱。比如，这是我最喜欢的版本。这可以说是实地指南这一概念的核心。但有太多东西并不完全符合这一点，而我们只是对它们感到兴奋，你知道的，尤其是新鲜事物。比如，当你带着一些关于我们从未在节目中涉及的事物研究回来时，那些是我最喜欢的，因为我经常会，你知道的，如果我已经报道过了，我就会觉得，哦，我懂了。我已经知道了。所以，当他带着巴滕贝格（蛋糕）以及各种其他东西回来时，你知道的，那才是我在着手写书时真正、真正感到兴奋的那类东西。
And for me, too, like, as a person who is, you know, a fan of the show for years before I joined the show. There was some fun in revisiting old, old stories and sort of looking at the raw material and looking at what had happened since those stories were published and sort of rethinking it all for the book. And, you know, like the Chicago River comes to mind. And, you know, we talked about the Chicago River, or you did in an old episode. Yeah, that was one we did years ago with Dan Wiseman. But, you know, in the book, we talk about it in a different way. You know, I found some more history to that that was kind of fun and interesting. And so what we ended up with in the book was this kind of combination of some things drawn from the episode, some sort of new developments in the
对我来说也是，作为一个在加入节目之前就已经当了多年该节目粉丝的人。重新审视老故事，审视原始素材，看看自从这些故事发表以来发生了什么，并为这本书重新思考这一切，这其中充满了乐趣。你知道的，比如芝加哥河就浮现在脑海中。而且，你知道的，我们讨论过芝加哥河，或者你在旧的一期节目中讨论过。是的，那是多年前我们和丹·维斯曼一起做的一期。但是，你知道的，在这本书中，我们以一种不同的方式谈论它。你知道的，我发现了一些关于它的更多历史，挺好玩也挺有趣的。所以我们最终写进书里的，是这样一种组合：一些取材于节目的内容，一些新进展
case, and then some more history too. So it's... Totally. It was fun for me to dive back into some of the classics and expand on that material as well. Yeah. And it really is a different thing to create a book versus to create a story for a podcast. You know, a lot of people asked us about like how it differs, like with audio storytelling in terms of structure and approach. When you're writing for audio, you know that it's linear. You know that people are only hearing it, you know, in order once, and they're not sort of scanning it the same way that they do when it comes to written text. And so there's this process of reiterating the point, you know, anecdote and reflection,
在这个案例中，还有更多历史。所以它……完全是这样。对我来说，重新深入研究一些经典作品并扩展这些材料也很有趣。是的。为播客创作一个故事与创作一本书确实是两码事。你知道的，很多人问我们它们有什么不同，比如在结构和方法的音频讲故事方面。当你为音频写作时，你知道它是线性的。你知道人们只能按顺序听一次，而且他们不会像阅读书面文本那样去浏览它。所以这是一个重申观点、讲述轶事和进行反思的过程，
anecdote and reflection, and reiterating a point. And it is something that it does not work in text. And it was something that was really clear when we started working with Kate, our editor at HMH. She really helped guide and put us in a direction towards a more written format. It was just learning a new skill, especially for me, for sure. Oh, for me too. And just the leveling up that happened as we got more involved with them and involved them more in the process. So for us, we started out writing essays and it started to graduate towards sections.
轶事和反思，以及重申观点。这是行不通的。这是文本中行不通的东西。当我们开始与我们在HMH的编辑凯特合作时，这一点非常明确。她确实帮助引导并指引我们走向更适合书面格式的方向。这简直就是在学习一项新技能，特别是对我来说，绝对是。哦，对我也是。随着我们更多地参与其中并让他们更多地参与到流程中，我们的水平也在不断提高。所以对我们来说，我们一开始是写散文，然后开始逐渐发展到各个部分。
But, you know, soon enough, we were sending these essays and sections to the editor and getting back feedback at the kind of granular level. And then it took a long time to kind of build that up into these larger chapters. And each stage of the review, it was like we would send something bigger and wait a little longer, but get more feedback. But fortunately, early on in the process, we did get a lot of guidance from them about what does and doesn't work in a book. which helped us decide, you know, how are we going to tie different stories together? It turned out I had this idea early on that, you know, each story would really clearly dovetail with the next. Yeah, and they did not want that. Kate was just like, no, people will not read it that way. I remember each one, we, we, you and I, like, labored over these handoff final sentences that would lead right to the next essay.
但是，你知道的，很快，我们就把这些散文和章节发给编辑，并收到颗粒度非常细致的反馈。然后花了很长时间才把它构建成这些更大的章节。在审阅的每个阶段，就好像我们会发一些更大的东西过去，等待稍久一点，但能得到更多的反馈。但幸运的是，在流程的早期，我们就从他们那里得到了很多关于一本书中什么可行、什么不可行的指导，这帮助我们决定，你知道的，我们要如何把不同的故事串联起来？事实证明，我早期有个想法，你知道的，每个故事都应该与下一个故事非常清晰地衔接在一起。是的，他们不希望那样。凯特当时就觉得，不，人们不会那样阅读它。我记得每一个故事，我们，你和我，都在这些交接的最后一句上煞费苦心，希望能直接引导到下一篇散文。
And Kate, Kate Napolitano, who was like a fantastic editor who did an amazing work with us, you know, was kind of, was kind of, was kind of, was kind of just like, you don't need to do this. Like, if they're going to read the next one, they're going to read the next one. If they're not, and if you really mean it that people can skip around and read different parts, then it just doesn't help. And it was like, oh, yeah, I guess you're right. But I remember, like, we had all, I'm trying to think of like, if there was one type of sentence most consistently cut, it was probably one of these, like, pithy handoff sentences that leads correctly to the first paragraph of the next essay. Right. And we ended up with a kind of compromise where it's like if you do keep reading, you will connect the dots. We're not going to connect those dots for you. But if you're reading straight through, it's like a little Easter egg. You know, like you're reading straight through. You'll catch on to the connections between these different pieces. But you're not kind of forced to read straight through in order to make those connections.
还有凯特，凯特·纳波利塔诺，她是一个非常棒的编辑，跟我们合作得非常出色，她当时就觉得，你根本没必要这么做。如果读者打算读下一篇，他们自然会读；如果不读，而且如果你真的希望大家能跳着读、阅读不同的部分，那么这种过渡句就完全没用了。当时我就想，哦，对啊，我想你是对的。但我记得，我们当时把所有的内容——我在想，如果说有什么类型的句子是最常被删掉的，大概就是这种简练的过渡句，它们原本能顺畅地引出下一篇文章的第一段。对吧。最后我们达成了一种折衷：如果你继续往下读，你会自己把这些线索串联起来，我们不会为你把这些点连起来。但如果你是从头到尾顺着读的，这就好像是一个小彩蛋。你知道的，如果你连贯地阅读，你就会捕捉到不同篇章之间的联系。但你并不是被迫非得从头到尾连着读才能发现这些联系。
either and you can jump around exactly exactly and it was all that whole process everything about the process a was i think you know pretty smooth like it it was like a really good they were good collaborators in in a sense but one of the things it was just really different was the timeline of a book i mean like you know we do a show every week it takes maybe six to eight weeks to make an episode of the show so there's always this constant churn you put out articles you know, like there was a little bit less of them when you were working on the book. Yeah, I had to set some of that aside a little bit. Of course, which you needed to.
而且你可以到处跳读，完全没错。整个过程，关于制作过程的一切，我认为都相当顺利。比如，这真的是一次很好的合作，他们是非常棒的合作者。但其中有一点非常不同，那就是书的创作时间线。我的意思是，我们每周都做一个节目，制作一集节目大概需要六到八周的时间，所以一直有一种持续的运转，你需要发布文章。你知道，当你写书的时候，文章的数量会稍微少一点。是的，我不得不把其中一部分稍微搁置了一段时间。当然，这也是必须的。
But, you know, we're very used to a production process that has a different metabolism than that of a book creation. Having a long deadline that's really far in the future, like what is what happens with the book, is terrible. And what makes it almost excruciating is having a weekly deadline that run. in parallel to that deadline. Well, and the only way the long deadline of the book worked really was to break it down into these shorter deadlines and to say, okay, well, we're going to have a version of chapter 1 by X and a version of chapter 2 by Y. It's like, where do you start? How do you find the kind of motivation to do this if you don't? And yet, one of the surprises to me, I mean, I look back and I think it's so silly, but I told, you know, friends and friends and
但是，你知道的，我们非常习惯一种生产节奏，它和创作一本书的节奏完全不同。有一个非常遥远的长期截止日期，就像写书这样，这简直太可怕了。而更让人感到备受折磨的是，在那个长期截止日期的同时，还得应付每周都有的死线。嗯，要让书的那个长期截止日期真正发挥作用，唯一的办法就是把它拆解成这些较短的截止日期，然后说，好吧，我们要在某某时间之前完成第一章的一个版本，在某另一个时间之前完成第二章的版本。这就好比，你从哪里开始呢？如果你不这样做，你又怎么能找到动力去做这件事呢？然而，让我感到意外的是——回顾过去，我觉得这太傻了——我曾经对朋友们说...
family towards the end of 2019. I'm like, well, we're almost through the hard part. And, you know, it seems so naive in hindsight. It's just, it's a process. And it keeps going. And as soon as you're done with one thing, you've got to kind of move on to the next, whether it's working with the illustrator and working with the designer, there's always something to be done. And the text is part of that. And the text is a key part of that. But it isn't all of it. For sure. No, not by a long shot. It was just deciding. on illustrations and in design and color and the printing and, you know, just everything about it was just so complicated. And one of those things that we were really involved in because one of the
还有2019年底的家人。我说，好吧，我们快要熬过最艰难的部分了。现在回想起来，这显得太天真了。这只是一个过程，而且它一直在继续。一旦你完成了某件事，你就得继续推进下一件，无论是和插画师合作还是和设计师合作，总有做不完的事。文本只是其中的一部分，文本当然是关键部分，但它并不是全部。肯定的。远非如此。仅仅是决定插画、版式设计、颜色以及印刷，你知道的，所有这一切都太复杂了。而且这是我们深度参与的事情之一，因为...
pitfalls of having a show about design is that the book you make better be good. You don't think it better to look good. It better read well. It better flow. It better have a reason for existing. That was my main thing, is like, I already get the opportunity to tell millions of people stories about design. So why should a book exist? And what can it do that the show can't do? And that's something that we were constantly thinking about of how to exploit those differences between a book and a podcast and a website. And so all those things required so much thought. I mean, so much so that I think HMH was shocked at the level of detail, especially you were writing them with. Well, yeah, I mean, I think they expected, you know, they're used to authors, authors are authoring, right?
做一个关于设计的节目，其中一个陷阱就是，你做出来的书最好足够好。不仅要看起来好看，还要读起来顺畅，得有排版节奏，还得有它存在的理由。这是我最核心的想法：我本来就已经有机会向数百万人讲述关于设计的故事了，那么为什么还要出一本书呢？它能做什么而节目做不到呢？这是我们一直在思考的问题：如何利用好书、播客和网站之间的这些差异。所有这些都需要大量的思考。甚至可以说，HMH出版社对我们关注细节的程度感到震惊，尤其是你参与写作的那些部分。嗯，是的，我的意思是，我想他们原本的预期是，你知道的，他们习惯了那种由作者独立创作的作者？
They're writing. They're doing the text stuff. But of course, you know, we're interested in design. So we want to work with the designer. We want to work with the illustrator. We want to, you know, make this a designed object. And I have this background in architecture. And so I'm not a great designer, but I at least like the process and know how it works.
他们在写作，处理文字方面的东西。但当然，你知道的，我们对设计很感兴趣。所以我们想和设计师合作，想和插画师合作，我们想，你知道的，把这本书打造成一个设计精良的实体对象。我有一点建筑学的背景，所以我虽然不是什么优秀的设计师，但我至少喜欢这个过程，也知道它是如何运作的。
And so a lot of it was sort of navigating this challenging thing, which you always have to navigate with designers, which is to say, figure out what their strengths are. So we spent, for example, a lot of time looking at the portfolios of both Patrick Vale and Raphael Geroni, who, were the illustrator and designer of the book and saying, okay, how can we lean into their strengths? How can we sort of give them the freedom to do what they do well, but make sure we also cover the things that we need to cover in the course of this design process? Yeah. So when we went through and took every story we've ever told in whatever format and put it into a big spreadsheet and ranked them from one to five about what to include in the book, we both quickly settled on the first one being the official graffiti. It had an explosion. It seemed like a good thing that people would see everywhere. There was a story behind it. We could teach people how to decode it in ways that were really fun and obvious. And so I remember that being kind of one of the first ones we settled on. This leads me to one of the last ones we included. So there was a drama in San Francisco with these boulders, which is in chapter six, which is really the last story that we included at all. And I remember you asked,
所以很大程度上是在处理这个极具挑战性的事情——你和设计师合作时总是需要面对的——那就是弄清楚他们的长处在哪里。比如，我们花了很多时间研究帕特里克·维尔（Patrick Vale）和拉斐尔·杰罗尼（Raphael Geroni）的作品集，他们是这本书的插画师和设计师。我们在想，好吧，我们如何才能发挥他们的长处？我们如何既能给他们充分的自由去发挥所长，又能确保在整个设计过程中涵盖我们需要呈现的内容？是的。所以当我们把我们讲过的每一个故事、用过的每一种形式都整理到一个大表格里，并按一到五星对是否收入书中进行评级时，我们很快都决定把第一篇定为“官方涂鸦”。里面有爆炸的元素。感觉这是一个大家到处都能看到的标志，背后还有一个故事。我们可以用非常有趣且显而易见的方式教大家如何解读它。所以，我记得这是我们最早确定下来的内容之一。这就让我想到了我们收入的最后一篇。旧金山曾发生过一起关于这些大石块的风波，这在第六章里，其实这也是我们收入的最后一篇故事。我记得你当时问我...
me like, like, is this worth it? You know, like you, I'm pretty bedraggled and tired from the other 400 pages. It just felt like, like, I also was worried. I was like, is, is the publisher going to say, guys, you have to stop adding stuff? Please. And so I was like, you know, can we, can we convince them to just sneak this one last piece in? And it sort of encapsulated so much of what we were talking about already in Chapter 6 that it was just like, yeah, I think we got to do it. And one of the questions that we've gotten asked too is, you know, what's your favorite piece? And that's hard to nail down. I really like the first piece in the book. I do think it sort of captures the essence of the book really well. But in some ways, some of my favorite pieces are the ones I had to
我像是在问：这值得吗？你知道的，就像你一样，经历了前面400页之后，我已经精疲力竭了。我当时就觉得，我也很担心。我在想，出版社会不会说：“伙计们，求求你们别再加东西了？”所以我就在想，你知道的，我们能不能说服他们把这最后一部分悄悄塞进去？它完美地概括了我们在第六章中已经讨论过的大量内容，所以感觉就像是，好吧，我们必须把它做进去。我们经常被问到的一个问题是，你最喜欢哪一部分？这很难界定。我真的很喜欢书中的第一部分，我确实觉得它很好地捕捉到了这本书的精髓。但在某些方面，我最喜欢的一些部分反而是那些我不得不...
fight for. Yeah. So there was some consideration of cutting a few pieces, one of which was the piece about standardized time. Right. Right. This was the story of how different towns had to find start coordinating their clocks because the train was coming and they had to get on the same schedule. And what I realized sort of going back over it is that it wasn't super clear. It was probably too long. I could see how it wasn't working. But I really thought that the ideas in it were worth keeping and that it was a story worth telling just in shorter form. Yeah. And so it became one of my favorites because it became one I had to work on in order to justify keeping it in the book. Basically. Yeah. I do, I remember us sitting at my kitchen table and us going over that one and me being one of the naysayers who just was like, this is too complicated. Like people are not, people can't do math in this, in this way. And asking you questions about like, why is this important? And having you, you know, obviously just come through with it. And I remember, you know, like, I've more recently, you know, had the deep dive with the book because I've been reading it, you know, in,
力争保留下来的内容。是的。当时确实考虑过删掉一些篇章，其中之一就是关于标准时间的章节。对的，对的。这是一个关于不同城镇如何开始协调他们的时钟的故事，因为火车要开过来，他们必须调到同一个时间表上。我重新审视后意识到，这部分写得不够清晰。可能太长了，我能看出它当时行不通。但我真的认为其中的想法值得保留，而且这是一个值得讲的故事，只要改成较短的形式就行。是的。所以它成了我最喜欢的内容之一，因为它成了我为了证明它有资格留在书里而必须下功夫修改的部分。基本上就是这样。是的，我还记得我们坐在我家的厨房桌子旁，一起过那一节内容，我是唱反调的人之一，当时就觉得：这太复杂了，人们根本不会、没办法用这种方式做数学。我还问你诸如“这为什么重要”之类的问题，而你，你知道的，显然把它完美地解释清楚了。我记得，你知道的，我最近重新对这本书进行了深入的研究，因为我一直在...
in the studio out loud and that's a great section it really works like you did a great job making that like relevant and not complicated and make people understand what it really meant to standardized time when this was not a concern of people at all for uh you know millennia you know yeah and and i remember that conversation too and and it was like i needed i got it like i understood why I was so attached to it. But I needed some way, I basically needed you to talk to and you just explain it to me. Like don't read it, just explain it to me. And once I did, you saw the kind of passion I had for it. I think we both realized, okay, there's something here. It's just not fully on the page right now. Yeah. Yeah. So it's like we got to go back to the drawing board a bit and
在录音室里大声朗读它，那真是一个极棒的章节，效果非常出色。你把它处理得通俗易懂且不显繁琐，做得真的很棒，让大家明白了“标准化时间”在千百年来人们根本不将其视为问题的时代里，到底意味着什么。是的，我也记得那次对话，当时我明白了，我理解为什么我对它有那么深的感情。但我需要某种方式，基本上我需要你跟我对话，然后你把它解释给我听。就像是别去读那些文字，直接讲给我听。一旦你这么做了，你就看到了我对它的热情。我想我们俩都意识到，好吧，这里面确实有好东西，只是当时还没有完全呈现在纸面上。是的，是的。所以我们就好像得重新回到画板前去...
and figure out how to simplify this and streamline this so that it's just a compelling story. So it has been five years since we published the book, 15 years since I started the show, and actually 10 years ago this month, Kurt Kolstad started working with us. All marvelous things to celebrate, And the best way to do that is to get yourself a copy of the 99% Invisible City.
弄清楚如何将其简化和精简，使其成为一个引人入胜的故事。自从我们出版这本书以来已经过去五年了，自我开始做这个节目已经15年了，而实际上，就在本月的10年前，库尔特·科尔斯特ッド（Kurt Kolstad）开始和我们一起工作。这些都是值得庆祝的美妙事情，而庆祝它们的最好方式就是去买一本《99%隐形城市》（The 99% Invisible City）。
Go to 99PI.org slash book. It's available in hardback and audio format. If you want to listen to me, read it to you for 11 hours. You can do that too. You can even get yourself a signed copy. It's all available at 99PI.org slash book. This episode originally aired in 2020 and was produced. by me and Kurt Kolstad. Remixed by Martine Gonzalez, music by Swan Real. Kathy 2 is our
访问 99PI.org/book。它有精装版和音频版。如果你想听我为你读上11个小时，你也可以选择那个版本。你甚至可以买到签名版。所有这些都可以在 99PI.org/book 上找到。本集最初于2020年播出，由我和库尔特·科尔斯特ッド制作。由马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martine Gonzalez）重新混音，音乐由斯旺·里尔（Swan Real）创作。凯西2世（Kathy 2）是我们的...
executive producer. Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Barube, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Lay, Lashemadon, Joe Rosenberg, Kelly Prime, Jacob Medina Gleason, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of his logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Series XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north, in the Pandora building in beautiful uptown oakland california you can find us on all the usual social media sites as well as our own discord server there's a link to that as well as every past episode of 99 p i at 99 p i dot org There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
执行制作人。德兰尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）是我们的资深编辑。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁布（Chris Barube）、杰森·德莱昂（Jason DeLeon）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、薇薇安·莱（Vivian Lay）、拉谢马顿（Lashemadon）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、凯利·普莱姆（Kelly Prime）、雅各布·梅迪纳·格利森（Jacob Medina Gleason），还有我，罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。99%隐形的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）创作。我们是天狼星XM（Sirius XM）播客大家庭的一员，现在总部设在美丽加州奥克兰上城区潘多拉大厦以北六个街区。你可以在所有常规社交媒体网站以及我们自己的Discord服务器上找到我们。在那上面有一个链接，可以通往99PI的每一期往期节目，网址是99PI.org。本集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。